I took a very simple degree a two-year  to wartime degree at the end of the war  at Cambridge and then I served in the  Navy for a few years and the thought of  going back on her to a ground didn't  appeal to me is that the way that  doesn't appeal to people in their early  twenties and but I'm not sure that I  would ever have been a decent scientist  I mean I say how I envy you actually  having drawn in my romantic way drawn  the veil away from the face of truth and  you've seen a little bit something that  nobody else has ever seen before you how  wonderful that must be and the say oh  yeah what it's taken me 35 years of  sitting in this one doing that is I just  wish that had the opportunities you to  go to the deserts or the polls or  whatever it is where you mean so you  can't have everything  you